Gaming in general has been getting
increasingly popular over the last
decade but mobile gaming like using an
iPad has blown up in the last couple of
years
thanks to massive advancements in
processing power and because of that we
are seeing more and more actually great
and fun multiplayer games coming to
mobile devices like Call of Duty mobile
pub G fortnight and games like vainglory
so those are the games that we're going
to be testing in this video and we'll be
playing them on each iPad and Apple's
current lineup starting with the budget
10.2 inch iPad currently on sale for two
hundred and seventy nine dollars the
iPad Mini five for three hundred and
fifty dollars the iPad air three for
four hundred and seventy nine dollars
and the 20/20 iPad pro for seven hundred
and ninety four dollars now we already
compared to everything about these four
iPads to see which one you guys should
buy but the point of this video is to
see which one of these iPads is the best
choice for gaming for your specific use
case because what some people think of
gaming is simply playing games like
clash of clans clash royale or similar
games like that that are so easy for
either of these iPads to run that it
really doesn't matter which iPad you
choose and for simple games like that
the budget 279 dollar iPad is going to
be just fine but on the other hand there
are people who take gaming so seriously
that they must have the fastest
processor the highest refresh rate
display and the fastest Wi-Fi connection
so that there is absolutely no lag or
performance issues at all when they're
playing competitively against real
players online and that's what we're
going to find out in this video so here
are a few benchmarks showing the
differences in processor and graphics
performance between these iPads and one
thing you'll notice is that the iPad
Mini and air are almost identical and
that's because they have the same exact
chip so let's start off this comparison
by playing vainglory
on the 10.2 inch budget iPad as far as
performance I was able to play on this
basic iPad with no issues at all
everything was pretty smooth and it was
very easy to play competitor
however is definitely not very
comfortable holding it in your hands
while playing so I preferred laying it
down flat on a table moving on to the
iPad Mini I instantly noticed a couple
of things first off the speaker sounded
better and louder than on the regular
iPad and it was also pretty comfortable
to hold because of the smaller size and
lighter weight and I noticed that there
were less reflections on the display
says the mini and the rest of the more
expensive iPads have an anti-reflective
display and I noticed better contrast
and colors as well performance didn't
really change since the regular iPad ran
it just fine so I don't expect any
differences with the other iPads now
with the iPad air the size went back up
so it wasn't as comfortable to hold and
performance was identical but the
speakers were even louder and better
than the other two iPads but it wasn't
that big of a difference in general now
moving on to the 20/20 iPad pro the game
felt more immersive since we no longer
have the big bezels that come with the
home button and holding this in my hands
definitely gave me a different feel
because of the squared off edges a huge
difference was in the speaker's since
the iPad pro is the only one to get them
on both sides so you get true stereo
sound while playing and landscape mode
and the quality and volume was much
improved compared to the rest as far as
performance the main difference was that
vainglory actually supports 120 FPS
gaming on the iPad pro so everything
felt incredibly smooth and fluid
compared to the other iPads which have
60 Hertz displays now moving on to pop G
this game still doesn't support 120 FPS
so it doesn't have that benefit but
let's start with the budget 10.2 inch
iPad interestingly even this iPad allows
you to choose extreme framerate
in the graphics settings with balanced
mode turned on which means it should be
able to get a maximum of 60 FPS and I
made sure to disable auto adjust
graphics and then enabled anti-aliasing
to put some extra load on it in terms of
performance it was actually pretty
smooth in general but I did notice times
where it would drop frames and be a bit
stuttery especially in environments with
textures but I enjoyed the quite large
10.2 inch display and while performance
wasn't the best I was pleasantly
surprised to see that you can actually
get a decent pub G gaming experience on
this iPad moving on to the iPad Mini I
really enjoyed how easy it was to hold
in one hand and play but I did notice
that the smaller display size media a
bit tough to see enemies that were
further away as far as performance
I noticed those stutters and drop frames
go away because of the better processor
so everything felt really smooth one
thing to keep in mind is that the
smaller size also leads to a smaller
battery so you could see significantly
lower battery life for gaming and ask
for the iPad air performance was
identical the only real difference I
noticed was simply the larger size
making it easier to see enemies but
noticeably less comfortable to hold in
your hands which might not matter to you
if you play with your iPad on a stand or
laying on a table and finally onto the
iPad pro I didn't really notice any
difference in performance since this
game doesn't yet support 120 FPS and
unfortunately you can't go any higher
than balanced on the graphics settings
while playing at extreme framerate which
is ridiculous since I know it can handle
better graphics at 60fps and as far as
gameplay there was a massive advantage
in terms of the speaker quality because
it makes it much easier to track
footsteps of enemies around you but
other than that there was no real
advantage to using the iPad pro moving
on a fortnight I decided to put each
iPad on a stand in play using an Xbox
one controller starting with the 10.2
inch iPad it's nice to see that there is
now a 60 FPS option on this iPad while
at medium settings whereas before it was
limited to only 30 FPS and just looking
at the lobby the quality of the
characters and textures isn't that great
and that lucky' quality translated over
into the game with there being quite a
bit of aliasing and it was easy to tell
that the quality was lacking in terms of
performance even though it was set to
60fps it was actually hovering around 40
to 50 FPS most of the time so it didn't
feel that smooth
and there were even times where the FPS
dipped into the 20s and there was
noticeable stuttering so I would
definitely not recommend this budget
iPad if you want to play competitively
as for the iPad Mini we had the same 60
FPS at medium quality settings as the
regular iPad but the graphics were
drastically more detailed in the lobby
even at identical settings so that's
something to keep in mind and in the
game itself the detail was much better
as well as far as performance the
framerate was basically maxed out at
60fps the entire time which shows us
that it can easily handle medium
graphics and should have an extra high
graphics option but it doesn't and since
we're using a controller the comfortable
size didn't really matter and I noticed
that I had to sit closer to the display
to see enemies that were further away
now for the iPad air the graphics
settings were identical since it uses
the same a 12 chip and the performance
didn't change either the only two
differences I noticed were really just
the more convenient display size while
using the controller and the better
speakers there are also a lot of players
who used the claw method for playing
fortnight and this iPad would be a great
choice for those people finally onto the
iPad pro which is basically every mobile
fortnight players dream tablet as you
can see in the settings we now have a
120 FPS frame rate option because this
iPad pro has a 120 Hertz display
unfortunately you can only take the
graphics up to medium but I think it
could handle higher frame rates if they
allowed for it
gameplay on this iPad was great because
it stuck to 120 fps almost all the time
and there was a night-and-day difference
between the pro and the other iPads in
terms of gameplay smoothness the whole
experience in general is better since
you have the much better speakers on
both sides for listening to footsteps
and the display can actually get
brighter than the rest which would be
nice if you're playing in a bright
environment so the iPad pro is easily
the clear winner for playing fortnight
giving you huge advantages over the
other iPads and now let's finish off
with call of duty mobile which also has
controller support on the 10.2 inch iPad
we set the graphics too high which
unlock the max framerate which should be
60fps and while playing the game it was
surprisingly well optimised and played
very well although I did notice some
dropped frames every now and then but
overall you could buy this iPad for a
decent Cod mobile experience
the iPad Mini had the same exact
settings but it did feel a bit snappier
and more responsive in the lobby
compared to the budget iPad even though
the settings were the same the mini just
felt more smooth and fluid and as far as
the small display issue this wasn't as
big of a deal
since Call of Duty tends to have smaller
maps and multiplayer mode but it could
be an issue in the battlegrounds mode
their performance and everything was
basically identical on the iPad air
except for the larger display which is
definitely the better choice if you plan
on using a controller and you should get
better battery life as well and finally
all the iPad pro the settings were
surprisingly the same the graphics
didn't really look any better and it
didn't support 120 fps so there wasn't
really any real advantage over the iPad
air except for the stereo speakers for
listening to footsteps so after playing
all of those games here are are buying
recommendations for each of these iPads
in terms of gaming if your idea of
gaming is playing things like clash of
clans then the 10.2 inch ipad is perfect
for you insane for those who play MOBA
games like vainglory since the
performance is good enough for games
like that and it's much cheaper at the
279 dollar price but I would honestly
recommend gamers to upgrade the storage
to at least 128 gigs so you don't have
issues of running out of storage while
downloading games and if you want to
play call of duty mobile or pop G and
you aren't very competitive and don't
really care about having a perfectly
smooth gaming experience
then the 10.2 inch iPad is still a
decent buy now if you do care about that
and you play these games especially for
tonight you're gonna want to buy at
least the iPad Mini or the iPad air for
the better display quality and the more
powerful a 12 chip this will give you
perfectly smooth 60fps gameplay
across any of these games and if you're
someone who likes holding your iPad in
your hands while gaming then the iPad
Mini is the best choice but keep in mind
that the small size could mean lower
battery life but if you play using the
controller or the claw method then the
iPad air is definitely a better choice
than the mini but it's also $100 more
expensive now if you're extremely
competitive with your gaming or if you
play Fortnight then the iPad pro is by
far the best choice because you know you
won't have any performance issues at all
and that 120 Hertz display is amazing
for games like Fortnite with support 120
FPS the quad speaker system is also
great if speaker quality is important to
you and it has by far the best display
quality out of the bunch and on top of
that it supports Wi-Fi 6 which could be
very important to competitive players
who want the least amount of lag so if
you want the king of all tablets for
gaming then you've got to go with the
iPad pro and a major benefit is that the
20/20 iPad pro base model for 794
dollars already comes with 128 gigs of
storage so you're good to go for
downloading a bunch of games on it
hopefully this video helps you make a
decision on which iPad to buy for gaming
and will have links to the best deals on
each of these iPads in the description
below now if you don't care that much
about gaming check out our massive full
comparison between these iPads right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]